yay hello welcome to this broadcast
someone asks I'm not late am i no you
are not i just started this broadcast
right on time not one second too late i
believe yeah i hope you all enjoyed the
world cup currently going on in baku
some nice action i didn't look at
today's games there should have been
first games around to have to check that
um yeah on a lighter note thanks for
everybody who watched my video last week
the game where played a the cheetah on
the hipon the ICC it's my most popular
video to date thanks for all watch that
and yeah posted fun commentary and so on
ok I'm going to start um please give me
a short notice that I'm really live so
like to do that someone actually wrote
recently that I should stop doing that
this is unprofessional it's not it's not
just how it is sometimes twitch is
acting up ok i'm going to start and it
seems i am live let's start with a five
minute game i'm sitting on a pretty high
rating had a good run recently um
someone says looking forward to seeing
via he vs aronia that is a cool pairing
is that is said on already ok i'm
playing kill the yarn here mr. carlo
tomorrow yeah we both have pretty high
ratings as you can see i play this line
that's an interesting line Bishop g5
yeah I'll just develop I've got a minus
one score against him someone says it
will be likely next round valuers
aronian yeah that's cool hmm and night
takes maybe it's not so bad someone
asked me how about how am I today yeah
I'm fine thanks a lot still enjoying the
last days that can can be called summer
let's say still have pretty good weather
in Germany ok taking with the e porn
here looks like a fairly solid position
yeah deform him he wants to play against
an isolated pawn but I'm not complying
rookie one is good now preventing Bishop
is six but ok I go rook e8 I go bishop
no it is that ok I'm taking it's a
simple solution and Bishop e6 Bishop of
seven someone someone says they had a
terrible tournament we played badly and
he said one reason for that might be
that there was a tournament right before
that and it was tired what to do what to
do we have in this kind of situation
where you feel badly um there is no
clear recipe really important this to
not yeah be shaken too much yeah someone
recommends the best thing is to just
relax and do not think about chess at
all do sports it's not a bad idea
actually get some yeah try to get some
movement and yeah do some
sports or at least them yeah do
something that makes you feel feel good
at some good recommendation someone
recommends get late yeah that's not a
bad idea actually but might have been
might be difficult for for all to
realize simply um yeah as I said do
something that makes you feel good that
is including the suggestion okay so why
it is somewhat better him I wonder how
to play exactly before yeah be 5f 985
hmm i wonder if i should go like age 65
and limit his pieces now difficult
someone asked when did when is my 12
came match versus mr. auriga's um I
don't see that happening really and i'm
really only playing against him if I
really must I never would voluntarily
enter match was against him so much as
he there some his confidence went down a
lot he had three don't don't don't worry
so much everybody has a bad event know
it then
at 16 you will look forward to many many
more matches someone asks can can I do
the brown cloud I certainly can but I
certainly won't I really don't like to
play I mean I tried a bit with playing
non-standard openings on a stream and it
really didn't didn't go well and the
bong cloud this is like this is just
totally terrible nonsense I don't do
that so the an interesting position here
Queen a4 was a bit surprising I wonder
what its idea
I don't I don't really understand his
idea maybe just wants to be annoying
someone says I what here what's the
Sicilian by playing to c4 and trying to
transpose into maroc see what you're
thinking of this towards the sea three
against the so you know that's a
playable line it's not it's not terribly
bad or so just not very ambitious
because you won't get amarok see against
good play so what about this year like
to get rid of this spinning situation
it's 98 or something that it looks kind
of passive
98 Queen 86 or something I don't really
see a big point down yeah let's trade
him I took on this seven yeah after Luke
cheeks he has a b5 unfortunately I now
saw that and not before it's a bit
annoying yeah I'm not great someone says
that the football club of my my town
where I am living is currently down by
two against against another club now I
don't care that much I follow football
but it's not not a huge concern if
duisburg-essen lose losing yeah why does
a bit better but not sure how bad it
really is it still feels fairly solid so
someone says can you tell tell us what
my favorite pro players are yeah like
top players in the in the world's top
and and there are a couple that I like I
guess I already mentioned that I like
aronian quite a bit it's got a very
interesting style of playing but there
are many many players that I think are
really really strong also Cal's is of
course an excellent plan I mean
especially his technical players it's
extraordinarily grade so I'm regrouping
here the night over to g6 looking at
their form one thing that I only now
noticed is I'm pretty much done on time
yeah I would for night at five now my
position is okay the time situation is
is not root g three
can pre move this now for a five and now
i have really have to look at this game
I can take a five stupid that was stupid
maybe I'm still okay here because no i
blundered this oops not stupid I was
just better here just better in this end
game crazy okay that I was very very
stupid okay um and do I think that going
g6 in the pan off is better than going
into the dry end game it's a bit
difficult maybe for people who don't
know what you're talking about yes I
think the g6 is much more interesting
much more interesting okay playing
psychic Grandmaster from Canada who is
that Thomas roussel Guzman I don't know
that guy okay i'm going with B six now
in that game against the judge that I
just lost I really lost because i was
talking too much I really didn't look at
the time and I wore sunday was so much
down on time position was excellent of
course yeah I'm trying with this offbeat
b6 line against see 492 well thats
pretty pretty ok let's go see five I
really don't know that player it's
totally unknown to me maybe I can
irritate them a little bit with stuff
like that
come on let's play something crazy
someone says I missed the reason why he
went back to three blitz games a day
just because I was down on one blitz
game and not back two three um yeah I
didn't feel like I need to announce it
it was just that i know i have a little
bit a little bit more time and i can't i
can do that i did add the one video
thing was for one week only I wanted to
keep that on one video but I really felt
that many people I'm said that they they
like to watch the three games and that
there was that to watch the three games
and I have that I at the time I really
had some spend lots of time for non
chest things for a while I totally
reorganized my home that that took took
a long time soon and what about this
this is a very weird position and not a
good one for me I tried something
creative and that's what you get I
sometimes think if I play the most
uncreated boring nonsense that I'm
scoring best and this is not one of them
someone says I don't get it someone
asked about am i living with my
boyfriend that sounds weird um no I'm
not hey I'm completely I'm single really
not looking for a boyfriend really
girlfriend would be okay everything
would fit but not not at the moment so
what what is this you want if five
that's interesting move okay I'm taking
and castling short isn't he five
somewhat weak now huh
like this 46 I don't know if that was so
great what he did interesting though d6d
six days there's probably six
yeah okay what is okay him when will my
league season start um yeah that's um it
or in November it's the simple answer
and there was um we are starting a bit
late because it's it's a bit strange
that the season starts next Sunday but M
the very first match is against the team
that withdrew from the league completely
and therefore we don't play we don't
play the second round is during at the
same time of the world world blitzen
trapper championships and this is
delayed yeah so it is some rescheduled
for for next year and so our first match
is November yeah very very late start
it's a bit of a bit of an issue I would
have liked to start a bit earlier but
what can you do Kim 36 I have to move
that Depot at some point someone says a
me and Simon Williams should do a dual
commentary blitz match yeah sure I would
do that no no question but um sound
Williams didn't contact me about this or
anything and I didn't I mean I wouldn't
mind doing that but I'm not actively
seeking seeking the seeking of this kind
of match am I the best player in my team
is the question um that's not so clear
we have 33 people are there are somewhat
even bye bye ello I am but only by like
one point or so I'm playing ball one but
our second board is
is also is this about the same strength
so Luke t8 was my intention rook da
druke f6 that's kind of awkward but I
can go rookie 5 here I think it's the
kind of situation where you really don't
want to play some putts a move am I
going to play against all the girls team
eventually haha that's a fun question I
don't know if he still plays in a German
team he played for a team that where it
would could have happened actually it's
not it's not completely a farfetch this
idea I played them I played against all
the girls in the German team blitz
Championships two years ago and it ended
in a draw he didn't dare to play this
dead end game over the board which which
I think was there was a wise decision if
he would have done so it wouldn't have
been good for his nose probably so um am
I not too porn up in this king and porn
endgame now I can just take him that is
probably easier
I hope I'm hope I'm not to miss touching
this now thats that's a win that's a
windows n gamma I go there b5 king d 5
b-4 cakes takes king of eight king be
five king is seven kings six king e6
king b 16 b 5 that's it's a win or not
ah Qing f-18 d6 okay beef fkd five
before King see for king of 84 takes
King takes before King is six ok this
one friend said quicker beef before
before takes I'm checking first takes
takes a dead to come on I'm winning this
right don't don't tell me I'm not oh no
wait I'm not winning this how
embarrassing I really miss counted the
Zen game that's bad okay that is very
embarrassing it was just so totally one
okay let's go for a new game ah Jesus so
um someone says they would like to see
some g for action now I'm not going to
play G 4 I can wait till hell freezes
over for that what did I do wrong there
d 4 was before right that it's not
working king of eight maybe that was a
very special is very strange I mean it
was just one temple maybe I I somehow
slip the temple anyway playing pot pie
here I think he just hit hit at one
point he that he was streaming a lot pot
pie someone else have I ever been
recognized on the street no I could have
taken g4 yeah maybe I'd made the wrong
move over there but poor and sometimes
to really stupid mistakes in those end
games I don't know ok let's develop here
someone says when I we know what helped
me most to improve when I was younger
and couple of things I think
very helpful thing was to analyze my own
games quite a bit and back then we
didn't have any computers which helped
yeah so you had to think for yourself
okay um ship him making some pressure on
that rook some of us have have ever been
to Russia no unfortunately not I would
have liked I was thinking about playing
them there was this is a rough lot open
I was actually at one point thinking
about participating but then it didn't
work out what I didn't get anything I
couldn't get any vacation time at the
office yeah that's a nice position here
than I have
and the question what was my verse chest
experienced by your opponent had bad
sportsmanship um Wow hmm I didn't really
there wasn't that much terrible
happening really to work over F through
keV 3 root G through him night f8 very
solid defense let's do this hmm oopsie
age yeah rook g3 that's maybe even night
h5 possible ok let's take no I don't
think that that you can seriously play
against yourself all the time like in in
ditional Bella I don't think so it
doesn't make much sense ultimately I
don't really have had such a such a bad
sportsmanship experience over the board
I really didn't mmm not in games against
me really
may is defending the sorel night age
some
yeah the I aeroflot open is established
but as indeed it's not as some strong as
it was some years ago yet tomorrow
there's a new show by the ICC with
international master John Watson ask the
master yeah refreshing the video stream
often helps twitches sometimes acting up
yeah so an interesting position here I'm
not quite sure if this is really good
for me I had a very active position
still have but mmm yeah this is kind of
annoying trying to set up some sacrifice
on age six but it's not so easy to get
it to work yeah look g3 is kind of
dangerous looking but he can I can take
age six here in this position even night
h6 is the move Queen age 60 ever what I
was thinking you can take on g4 look
chief for TX Texas check yeah let's take
it someone says Chris have I ever had a
hoagie I don't even know what that is
what is the hoagie I hope that's not
something inappropriate
yeah queen age six after yeah here I'm
taking g-form chick chick and I'm porn
up ray it's still not easy you can go
away five okay no I'm going at five that
is good yep that's a good that's good
now for white oak aged three was even a
bit more precise but I'm fine now yeah
looking at this weakness and now let's
see let's go here and then reroute yep
don't allow 90 for who he is the
footlong sandwich yeah like this the big
subs um like the big subset at subways
yeah I probably had one of those then
not recently though trying to reduce my
my intake if for before mmhmm yeah
probably still a good idea
I have no rookie 395 is a bit annoying I
didn't see that move coming
that was a bad idea efore really a bad
idea
cheek there she formed age seven okay
let's keep this
night see five to six if I get that in
everything is totally good and it seems
I am manage yep that looks nice now for
rookie eight
I'm not even at taking this I'm not even
a checking a seven that is stupid how
stupid is that why I'm slow have to be
quicker
no I have demo slip six seconds Oh would
have done that easily mostly I know um I
know that was bad someone says I bet he
like sausages like Venus and
frankfurters no I'm currently mostly
vegetarian okay with white let's go
against hah gay yeah it will be five
mouths lip what can you do at no time
playin hah gay from Spain yeah it's got
a very high rating at the moment is
usually in the 2200 this is the guy who
always plays 1b3 hmm what is this that's
a very it's an uncommon line anyway wow
really oh wait wait wait wait night
cheeks our King takes us okay it just
developed normally yeah of course I'm
not blaming a huge edge here but I have
the better structure a little bit
seasick spawn yeah I have white that's
indeed somehow I feel like I always have
black against him this is be three years
kind of getting boring against him
always placed one be three which always
feels a little bit like some kind of
sentence
yeah play one be three for the rest of
your life guilty as charged well it's
not that bad b3 is not a bad opening it
just feels a little bit strange to
really play it every game okay so yeah
stable I said a little bit so how do we
actually try for something here that it
will be difficult anyway hmm
LightSquared bishops trading this would
be good mmm-hmm so difficult
yeah that's not very inspiring I know
but didn't see anything better night be
two kings he three nights you form ya b3
is totally fine I have played b3 quite a
bit actually myself and when I was some
I'm a junior player on a little bit a
little bit of water especially if I
wanted to wanted to get out of the known
theory some of us how did I develop my
credible Board of Elders thanks for the
nice boots I don't know if they're that
this is so so incredible I mean you you
just play a lot and study a lot and said
that the times it gets it gets better
over time so you can really if you look
at many games it's really really helpful
what is this Bishop c5 to 95 96 check
for 98 he's got 96 to cover hmm no d5
not great
yeah and 98 that Sony idea attacking
those two pawns so I probably have to go
up it's so very drawers oh wait he can
maybe play c5 and c5 Kings 26 kindy
seven trying to trap my note I have to
play 96 then but ok thats that's good
that's ok before maybe let's go before
no now we can take c5 and then King c6
and playing very stupid stuff today
that's very stupid you can take c5
checking the six powers my think first
then flame you can just take a place t5
and win amazing that's amazingly bad be
formed just King c4 and why does a
little bit better a little bit at least
what does this move I don't get it it's
almost a self-made
okay you can also check first check on
d6
antiquing is okay and going up I mean I
have a yes but you really want to snatch
that pawn that sounds it looks weird
it looks incredibly slow but maybe it
works and maybe it really works I cannot
attack this pawn
can't believe it what a weird concept I
cannot detect this form
Ice King is far more active I losing
this end game is really really bad it
was just better for white clearly better
even now Kim that really did that was
really really terribly played by white
that didn't really want to see this mean
I just want to check that briefly I want
to go back that's I mean before was
stupid you can just take and play c5 I
just played this and I'm just better in
this end game a little bit at least very
stupid that's a second big endgame screw
up really really bad okay so next I
don't think why do I have the draw in
hand with 97 I don't see that I'm the
piece down I thought about it but I
couldn't really I didn't really see it
working at the question Queens Indian or
real goes in it seems like Queens Indian
has a lot more theory um um maybe it's
just different the recursion is leading
to more peace play more peace play
oriented stuff
um yeah the Queen's Indian 11
disadvantage of the Queen's indian from
a practical point of us black and said
white has so many lines available not
that they are all greater so they are
just a lot of them okay pont exhibition
King's pawn takes
f5 row okay
so you're saying that this isn't week on
e6 maybe maybe I don't believe it down
let's see night f-93 hmm interesting
interesting interesting okay I'm trying
to develop first and then think about if
I can do something probably black it's
okay yeah king of 7s defending that you
six okay defending that we porn on is
six
that is an incredibly close position
incredibly closed it's probably probably
really draw
a five lb five that's not a good idea I
think
is he really trying to play this for
wind that would be kind of cheeky but
maybe years we'd be six
each yeah maybe you can try will be six
hmm surprising really okay I'm trying
for active play against e6 and some of
us do I ever get tired or chess what do
you do when that happens sometimes
really think that it's kind of a
phenomenon I really never totally get
tired which is um yeah a bit crazy even
if I have this feeling like I don't want
to do a chance now I like a couple of
hours later I'm changing my mind this is
the Blitz in client playing on the
internet chess club the ICC yam as my
initial setup here was too sluggish I
lost too much time and now it's a kind
of yeah it's okay for him at least k
Knight b6 was my idea I have to him for
the tempo
no key and now I have to cover g4
unfortunately and he has a five as a
possibility some sometimes yeah i was
thinking okay one and Jim this is a pin
now
King over to d3 would be good so that
that rook on d to finally can move so he
really really really wants to win yeah
the problem is that let's try this
um I'm better now not sure if i can win
but better now 92 maybe a 92 no I have
Roo k 7 in this line that's important
okay so I'm grabbing now yes bishop is
not to work that much day on g7 so look
I could have gone on the 7th immediately
okay this now this is this first this is
better checking this and now okay soon
so it looks like finally an end game
that I'm winning yeah now we reside who
yeah it look be it looked him look be
good I I do follow the world cup games
but not closely it only started very
recently and I only looked at two or
three games that were interesting I
haven't looked at today's games for
example
yeah I will gain request out my opinion
about the Queens gambit exchange mmm
yeah it recently um I has undergone some
River evaluations and black seems to be
not that not that badly off and yeah
sure I mean white can still do that a
car by in the house he does place III
right mm-hmm I don't know yeah I don't
know that line to what I really should
should study it always getting getting
problems with with this line
Oh terrible why do they always play this
stuff that's kind of annoying really
awful I'm just awful
yeah that's just not very inspiring this
position why not 95 yeah I'm sitting I'm
sitting in a pin there immediately yeah
that's not very great but okay it's
important to not play be sixth sense
bishop a6 chip made had something to
avoid
intended Bishop e8 but he maybe has a
bishop f8 which is really awful yeah
this doesn't look great I know but maybe
I can regroup always have to be
optimistic and chess e5 what is he doing
then I don't know taking
yeah I'm playing in the frequent
opponents that's true I've played him
quite often y acabo mostly I didn't
really remember that he places this
year's c3 sian I'm not a huge fan of
that with black especially as I never
really studied a good line and this is
not radia if you have never studied a
good line against this is c3 sayin it
can look like the best opening ever hmm
seagoing a bishop f8 is the idea laughs
yuck
it's damned awful
yeah so someone says that you can say
that you can state your opinion on the
twitch s unlike play chess where where
you get banned for no reason yeah I have
to have to agree with that it's I never
got banned on play chess but I had it
once I once had a dialogue there with
one of the admins and this guy was a
total [ __ ] to be perfectly honest
someone wants me to play the French
defense my old bane maybe he could have
gone for an advanced french but he
didn't yeah someone says ever seen the
broadcast of the scene field cap where
yessir Sarah one explained the beautiful
words it's flush and I watched some of
the broadcast but not sure I'm really
not sure I think that's all where he
mentioned that word and it's it's indeed
German is a somewhat weird language at
times but we have some really really
nice words especially those some yeah
kind of those long combined now say they
can can be here can be really really
nice sometimes so I am yeah I'm a porn
down and he's got the bishop pair which
seems kind of awful can I somehow fight
though maybe we should be one or
something at least my king which was
kind of pushed around the
the whole time at least this is doing
something now hmm how does he keep those
pawns we should give 150 196
I have to do it anyway 96
oh no 94 no 94 gets interesting I can
take it I'm stupid and sometimes I
really think I'm just I'm just a total
total idiot you can just take that pawn
how difficult is it to see that amazing
amazing and it just has g3l age for our
stupid stuff yeah just a 4g 3h for our
cover I don't have a dog but he proved
my dog would probably win that ok d3 ok
maybe d3 as an option I SI SE SEI take
it back
so what now this should be one king you
1 Bishop see to King do too it's just
not working him
hey he could have one much easier t2i ft
2
it's hard to believe but I'm winning
this end game that was the worst from
both players ah we saw says I do not
know the meaning of zits flash could you
explain the meaning in English um yeah
that means to really am to being able to
play really long games and continue
continue to fight slowly grinding out
things yeah the best zits flash player
would probably be a of all time will
probably be wolf Anderson the Swedish
Swedish legend TI who won many many
games long games where he ground down an
opponent hmm someone says I want to play
the green fur do I need to learn the
king's indian against anti goon fault no
I don't think so you can play a
Greenfeld ish tire type of position
almost all the time there's really no
need to learn a king's indian ok so i'm
doing one more game against f viana
yeah cowboy also had good zits flush
okay yeah that's an interesting line
here that my opponent is playing think
queen bee three is the most testing but
it's been ages ages since I looked at it
so this was played in them Anand chromic
match in 2008 yeah Carlson says it's fly
she's also pretty good okie dokie
probably a 3 here I've got the bishop
pair just almost the same thing as
having a pawn so glad about that I don't
really I have my doubts that this is a
great line as he plated and he
definitely cannot take on before c8 is
hanging oops night Street forum okay
going by that's true someone says that
this line was recommended by EDD rings
book play the name zonia that's true
yeah and it's a good line in general
it's a good line okay can I do he's got
this mm-hmm sorry he's got this the
screen yeah that's a very it's kind of
shaky this position I wound up can he go
night-night xt4 as a thread maybe I just
do this for Bishop d3 happen sorry see
takes d4 Bishop d3 Queen a5 check be4
night before a before Queen a one Bishop
before
it should be good for white yeah g-form
may be empty for was an interesting move
but maybe you could have taken on d4 90
x t for f2 is hanging with something
that's close to a check made someone
says do i play any asian form of chess
such as shogi know absolutely nothing I
had don't have any objections or
something but it's not what I what I
ever did Bishop d3 and now Queen 85 be
for night before Queen a1 not
yeah gasps if you don't know where John
Watson he was doing the show tomorrow
he's the author of tons of books um gpo
he wrote down the best books on the
french defense for example and is very
well known as a big opening expert but
he also wrote a couple of very very good
books on chess strategy chess strategy
and action modern chess strategy and so
on and yeah he's really a big chess
expert you don't need to be a
grandmaster to be very knowledgeable
about chess and he's a very very good
example for that the only thing that I
have to say a critical about his show
tomorrow's it's also sure that I would
have liked to do so kind of kind of
what's the word yeah I would have liked
to do the show as well this one is cool
this show and I'm two minutes something
ahead on the clock in that final game
and blacks position looks really awful
how do i how do I manage to kill black
off here that looks really nice yeah
jealousy I forgot the word jealous or
envious am
okay thanks thanks for letting me know
Oh black resigned that game that flat
fields premature 2444 summer reading um
okay we are 10 minutes past the past the
chime let's do one more right let's come
on one more game ah ha gay again but
I've got I've got some mint ice cream
playing b3 I guarantee is going be free
I pre moving a five now come on play b3
yeah there we go you can really pre-move
that against them come on pre move a
phone ah yeah this guy again I was just
for fun that a 5a for business so let's
see i want that porn back here ha gay
you're not going to keep that porn that
almost looks like some kind of nîmes oh
right let's let's go here I might get
that back there I can take a couple of
times on c3 do I have something better
even text move will be Bishop d3 I guess
okay that lets that's too simple stuff
and regain that porn I'm too
materialistic want that porn back
c5 might be a move
this should have three really no okay
yeah a five is a business is not a
serious move but it's just that it was
just funny that he's always playing this
always playing a b3m okay can I get
something on the King side down like
with the rook coming over here rook g5
Queen g5 not really are maybe let's do
this just trying to be annoying it's
probably probably not so great but
anyway am i playing the streamers thing
on chess.com this is an icc stream guys
i won't mention what i do on chess.com
but i will play it right i will play it
so we got the trade down and next in
line is Luke a8 I want to pressure the
apron
rook b5 interesting
so going here yeah I need my queen back
that action on the kingside wasn't
leading to much so yeah now a4 is
hanging and maybe I can know he's really
playing well at the moment there I mean
usually he really makes a ton of
mistakes here and there I am a ton of
mistakes I'm sorry that was a bit too
harsh but he makes mistakes and he
really plays well at the moment I mean I
have a score like ninety percent or so
against him but currently not too shabby
yeah one thing is for sure chess network
won't play in the streamers challenge
okay let's see what about this end game
not much not much happens IAM just very
dry my back rank is kind of weak have to
be i have to be a bit cautious then he
hits normally not that high rated really
not it's like 2,000 rude and usually
loses against me and pretty drastically
okay so what is this he's playing the
endgame and why not um Joe wants to go
if five maybe after Quincy five he is
maybe slightly better after you five
it's nothing very nothing very serious
but
I'm stupid I'm stupid I'm playing this
very badly I wanted to go d5 but then he
of course sc5 hmm i don't know it's not
a big deal run not come on that cannot
be that bad no he takes wow that I
didn't expect okay
yeah that should be a drawl already
and what the heck is he doing why is he
playing so well that's not fair
oh I am down to 48 seconds this is
important I'm not threatening a single
check besides Queen a three
this is a draw I hope now it's a draw
that's a draw
yeah so draw him good good fight good
fight yeah I did tried everything there
was but it probably is a draw with that
open king okay that was a bit of
overtime 20 minutes one thing that i
wanted to mention that i also have a
twitch channel on my own that I don't
use normally but i will use it there
will be some kind of show on it in the
near future i had planned the show for
the end of September normally but it was
supposed to be the show um when I got to
20,000 subscribers on YouTube and by
normal subscriber rates it would have
been really end of end of the month but
I had this hit video last week which had
um yeah we when i move that gained
200,000 views and it also netted me like
400 2 for 500 subscribers and which
means i'm on to 20,000 subscribers now
and i will do some celebration stream
for that the only thing is i don't know
yet when and i will definitely announce
it beforehand it will be something
something longer and it will feature
questions and stuff yeah and the
questions will probably also be on
reddit and so on and there will be some
time before hand like like I would
announce it a week before so and I don't
really know yet when to do it I need to
find a good time spot for that um I just
wanted to let you know that something
like that is going to happen ok thanks
for watching tonight make sure to tune
in tomorrow to john shaw and yeah take
care till next week bye